this video is brought to you by
DraftKings now some people will say
Nashville has changed me I say that's
hogwash it's not Nashville
it's DraftKings the leader in Daily
fantasy sports is putting you in a
position to win millions of dollars
every week this regular football season
put in promo code Josh Wolf that's all
caps
j-o-s-h-w-o-l-f get in there now here's
what you got to do get yourself a
DraftKings team like I have you name it
like I did anal Intruder too don't worry
about it it's just what came to mind
first now you always start with Tom
Brady why handsome and he's got a butt
on his chin Tom M effin Brady you want
to find out all this information go
right into that box where I'm fingering
and hit that URL right here I'm in a
breath hit that you are
hit that URL
[Applause]
the latest weird thing that happened
happened in Dallas
and so there's a dude in the front row
wearing a kilt
and I've always wanted it and it was
sticky in Dallas like it is here so I
asked him I go hey
why they killed and he goes man I wore
it one day when it was super humid and I
haven't gone back to pants since
he said it is so comfortable he said if
you can get past the fact that Kilt is
just another word for skirt skirt
you're going to be really comfortable
and I asked him I go and he was he was
you know he was had red hair red beard
he he was on the wrestling circuit
smaller circuit in East Texas and he had
like this you know Irish leprechaun gig
thing he was doing you know and and so
he wore the Kilt everywhere and I asked
him I go oh I've always wondered though
I go uh
do you wear underwear under the kill
and he said I'm gonna tell you what I
tell everybody else
you got to lift it up to find out
foreign
you're challenging the wrong guy
[Music]
because I know everybody else said no
right he goes yeah well I go I'm gonna
lift that [ __ ] up right now
now guys here's a couple things you need
to know about me I grew up with three
other brothers
uh I like making people uncomfortable I
like to be made uncomfortable that is
that reminds me that I'm a [ __ ] life
do you know what I mean that reminds me
I'm like you know when you're you know
when you're [ __ ] like out of breath
it's like
you know
when your asshole's like I can't breathe
I can't breathe I can't breathe like
that
I love those moments right yeah sorry
this dude is super confident the front
Rowan is killed and I'm like how can I
make him a little more uncomfortable and
he goes you're gonna lift The Kilt I go
yeah I go hold on a second
and he goes are you gonna do that on
your knees I'm like does that bother you
he was like a lot
[Applause]
and I said well then I have to do it on
my knees
so guys I'm I'm full of bravado right
but inside I'm like oh am I gonna see a
human dick like
have I reached over and he goes you
ready I go I'm [ __ ] ready
and I I lift it up if you don't know
anything about a kilt Kilt there's two
sides of the kill one if you lift up one
side all you see is more Kilt and he
goes yeah yeah he goes you got the wrong
side
oh man
so I'm down here right
and and I asked them I go how many
people have ever lifted the kill before
he was none
okay
and I was just like
and I
lived to the kill
dick
not just dicks shaved redhead dick that
was I was like oh that's brighter than I
thought it was gonna be
[Applause]
yo and this dude was all potatoes no
meat you know what I'm saying it
his dick looked like it fell asleep on
his nuts just
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]